y
hola muy bienvenidos nuevamente a la
entrevista de france en 24 argentinas
comienza a escribir otra página en su
historia una mucho más inclusiva y
también empática ya que en la nación
sudamericana ya es ley el cupo laboral
travesti trans y entre otras
reivindicaciones la normativa contempla
que los tres poderes del estado nacional
hablamos de los ministerios públicos y
además organismos deben ocupar una
proporción no inferior al 1 por ciento
de la totalidad de su personal con
personas travestis transexuales o
transgénero y prevé además incentivos
para lo que es el sector privado no para
que este sector cumpla con la normativa
hablamos de incentivos económicos nos
acompaña paula arraigada ella es
activista trans feminista asesora
parlamentaria en el congreso de la
nación argentina ha sido una de las
propulsoras de esta ley de la que
estamos hablando y estamos además ante
la primera candidata trans a diputada
por el frente de todos paula arraigada
muchísimas gracias en primer lugar por
su presencia
como están buenas tardes y aquí por
supuesto hace ya este ja me imagino
paula una celebración absoluta en
argentina estamos ante un hecho
histórico no marca todo un hito no sólo
en argentina también en toda la región
de américa latina representa sin dudas
un paso fundamental en la reparación de
las desigualdades históricas y
estructurales no para que nuestra
audiencia internacional conozca más de
cerca el tema de paula cuáles son los
principales cambios en materia de
derechos laborales para las personas
trans ahora en argentina
bueno estamos empezando a hablar de
derechos laborales porque hasta este
momento no había derechos la mayoría de
nuestras compañeras estaban precarizada
estamos hablando de un colectivo que
tiene un promedio de vida de 35 a 40
años es el promedio de vida que tenían
los y las individuos en la edad media y
parte de esa ese promedio de vida tiene
que ver justamente con la ausencia de
derechos el poder ingresar al mercado
laboral formal lo que abre es una
expectativa de vida no solamente en lo
monetario sino también en esto de la
conformación de la ilusión que tienen
los seres humanos dentro de pueda de
poder proyectarse de soñar sé y sobre
todo esto que es maravilloso de poder
soñar se trabajadoras y trabajadores que
están algo que hasta hoy muchas de
nuestras compañeras trans travestis
hasta ahora no lo habían podido pensar y
esto es una ley que amplía derecho para
el colectivo travesti entradas pero
amplía derechos también para los
trabajadores y gas trabajado
porque está empezando a hablar de la
precarización laboral pero es una ley
que va generando vanguardia no solamente
para nuestro país sino que lo empieza a
instalar la discusión en el resto de la
región
a lamas paula de lo que es la ampliación
de derechos no genera por supuesto
oportunidades laborales pero va mucho
más allá de esto verdad porque tener un
trabajo no es sólo obtener un salario
sino que abre la puerta para disfrutar
de muchísimas otras cosas de la vida se
ganan otros derechos no además de los
puramente laborales
se gana el derecho al goce que no es
poca cosa porque los trabajadores y las
trabajadores por ahí que ya tienen
institución alistado el trabajo y el
derecho a descansar por ejemplo una vez
por semana o el descanso que prevé en
las vacaciones quince días al año y
salud de nosotros no habíamos podido
vivir y que a partir de ahora muchas
compañeras van a tener derecho a ese
ocio creador ese derecho también al
poder y descansar y solas y además
también normalmente a otro derecho que
hasta ahora no podíamos tener que es el
derecho a la salud el derecho a la salud
y el derecho a formarse y capacitarse
para desarrollar mejor sus transitarias
porque hasta ahora muchas de nosotras
apenas hemos terminado el colegio
secundario y eso también hoy habla de la
precarización laboral en no poder
acceder
a una educación media pero a través de
este proyecto de ley a través de esta
ley que se acaba de proclamar lo que se
hace es acompañar restituir eso que en
algún momento el estado nos ha dejado
por fuera entonces no solamente generar
empleo sino en generar la capacitación
para que el objetivo que se trate
cualquiera de nosotras pueda ser
alcanzado cuando casi sea bueno sin
dudas estamos hablando de un avance
enorme paula en en lo que es la
ampliación de derechos absolutamente
necesaria por supuesto pero también digo
esta ley nos habla de un contexto social
cultural hostil por llamarlo de alguna
manera verdad me refiero a que bueno el
solo hecho de que sea necesaria no una
ley para que sean contratadas personas
trans no se está hablando de una
sociedad de una cultura que si bien pudo
haber cambiado en algunos aspectos sigue
cerrando las puertas verdad
bueno nuestro gobierno lo que ha hecho
con esto es otorgar un derecho donde
había necesidades claramente hay una
manifestación que se atravesó a través
de la pandemia donde muchas de nuestras
compañeras no podían ni siquiera llevar
el mínimo sustento para poder vivir esto
ha sido resuelto por una decisión
política primero con un decreto que se
proclamó el año pasado en el 2020 y hoy
con la sanción de la ley lo que hace es
reafirmar este decreto y permitir que
muchas compañeras hoy sean empleadas y
hoy puedan tener una expectativa de vida
muchísimo mayor
esto abre conciencia sobre todo en la
región porque lo que le sucede a la
compañera es este promedio de vida esta
falta de derecho no solamente sucede en
argentina es algo transversal a nuestro
colectivo y sucede en todos los países
que podamos mencionar no existe un país
que pueda hablar de la avanzada
de un mejor bienestar para el colectivo
travestis trans es una pena que suceda
hoy en pleno siglo 21 donde todavía hay
algunas poblaciones que carecemos de los
derechos que son esenciales que son
derechos humanos para nuestra
subsistencia exacto paula eso apuntala
estamos hablando básicamente de derechos
humanos hablabas al comienzo de la
entrevista bueno no de la expectativa de
vida de 35 años no de las personas
travestis trans el acceso al empleo
formal salva vidas básicamente verdad
salva vida y genera oportunidades esta
ley viene a abrir puertas y abrir
oportunidades donde no las había
nosotras claramente no teníamos
oportunidades para entrar al mercado
laboral formal por eso el estado el
gobierno toma la decisión política de
generar algo que hasta ahora no venía
sucediendo esto no es algo que nació hoy
es algo que venimos luchando las
activistas las militantes partidarias
hace muchísimo tiempo entendiendo que no
había un contexto social que permitiera
que una mujer trans estuviera en la
súper atendiendo un supermercado que una
mujer trans fuera secretaria que una
mujer trans pudiera llegar hasta la
gerenta de cualquier este emprendimiento
o que también una compañera trans
estuviera en los espacios de decisión
justamente para poder pensar la política
pública no solamente para las compañeras
y compañeros trans señor para el resto
del pueblo pero en ese sentido y en ese
camino es que estamos siendo buenos al
canto hasta alcanzó esta conquista clave
histórica y que es un hito para
argentina y américa latina
ahora que el lugar se abre nos abren
nuevas luchas que sigue
hemos conquistado hasta hoy los derechos
la identidad que son los derechos
cívicos pero hoy nos faltan los derechos
políticos si bien podemos votar lo que
nos falta hoy que mejor dicho lo que hay
que construir y para eso necesitamos el
andamiaje de los espacios partidarios es
la representatividad que claramente
tenemos en el pueblo en el feminismo
pero no se termina de acordar dentro de
los espacios partidarios que nosotros
podamos ingresar a los lugares de
decisión en este caso de diputada de
senadoras de concejala no podemos
ingresar sin la decisión política y sin
que los que tienen que decidir los que
tienen que decidir decidan para que esta
población que ha sido vulnerada y que
claramente posesiona y
es definitoria y además tiene la voz
para poder modificar ciertas realidades
está en esos lugares de decisión no
podemos construir una sociedad
igualitaria y equitativa sin la
representatividad de todos los
colectivos no vamos a poder construir
una argentina justa una argentina libre
una argentina feminista y soberana sin
las trans y las travestis nos llegan
esos lugares de decisión pero estoy
segura que en esta elección va a haber
muchas compañeras que ocupemos esos
lugares y podamos decir que argentina es
un país plenamente libre donde reina el
amor y donde reina la igualdad ojalá que
así sea vamos llegando al final de la
entrevista paula pero bueno esta
pregunta apunta concretamente a algo que
ya esbozaba recién no que comenzamos a
hablar va a ser fundamental que se que
no se les den cargos simbólicos no por
llamarlo de alguna manera como para
decir que entre comillas se está
cumpliendo con el cupo laboral travesti
y trans es fundamental que ocupen bancas
de diputados por ejemplo
sí porque además quienes estamos en los
espacios partidarios no solamente
tenemos la potestad de hablar en base a
lo que nos ha ocurrido a nosotras como
travestis y como trans sino también
venimos a hacer el espejo de nuestra
clase social de las clases vulneradas
del problema que tenemos por lo menos
hoy aquí que es la pobreza en torno a la
de la vivienda el problema también del
de pleno trabajo y eso es algo de
nosotras también hemos venido trabajando
hace muchísimo tiempo para poder
instalar la voz de esos y esas que
representamos no solamente las trans y
travestis sino al resto del pueblo
argentino a lo largo de este tiempo nos
hemos esforzado y todos los días
caminando en distintos barrios para
entender y para comprender y para
escuchar pero sobre todo para ser parte
de esa gran lucha por la dignificación
de nuestro pueblo pero en el espacio
partidario al que yo pertenezco que es
el peronismo tenemos algo que lo tenemos
grabado en el pecho y lo que sentimos y
además lo decimos con mucho orgullo que
nosotros todos los días
nosotros todos los días trabajamos para
construir ese máximo ideal que sé que es
ir por la felicidad del pueblo y por la
grandeza de la nación
ahora nos quedan menos de un minuto pero
bueno para despedirnos quisiera pedirte
un mensaje no solo para los argentinos y
las argentinas para la comunidad
internacional en general no teniendo en
cuenta el antecedente que está marcando
la nación argentina que los sueños son
siempre posibles solamente hay que
ponerle al alma el corazón si el
objetivo es justo el objetivo se cumple
hay que ponerle el alma que pone el
corazón y luchar no entro legado es eso
la lucha pero también es la adquisición
de derechos y este derecho es parte de
esa lucha
paula arraigada muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en la entrevista de
cuidados 24 ha sido un placer dialogar
con usted
muchas gracias por favor gracias a ti
nuevamente a nuestra audiencia como
siempre les invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]
y
i